in the spa town of Buxton in Derbyshire
England there is a beautiful Blue Lagoon
it looks like a great place to go
swimming but you might want to read the
signs first the Blue Lagoon of Buxton
looks like something that was plucked
out of the Caribbean and dropped into
the English countryside it's in an old
limestone quarry that's been left
abandoned and it's filled in with this
magical Azur coloured water people love
to go swimming there they take little
boats there you can see YouTube videos
of people doing flips and jumping into
the Blue Lagoon of Buxton there's some
things you should know about the Blue
Lagoon before you get into it one sign
reads warning polluted water water is
known to contain car wrecks rubbish dead
animals excrement dangerous to swim in
due to high pH levels this can cause
skin and eye irritation fungal
infections thrush coz thrush general
gross nests think exclamation point
would you swim in ammonia or bleach and
I'm gonna guess the answer is probably
not so the water is not as beautiful and
crystalline and pure as it might appear
on first glance but people go swimming
there every summer without fail and this
really started to irritate the locals of
Buxton which is in and of itself a small
quaint spa town so it probably rubbed
them the wrong way that people weren't
going to the spas but we're going to
swim in an abandoned limestone quarry
that was filled with garbage and as they
kept telling people the Blue Lagoon of
Buxton has a pH level of 11.2 ammonia
has a pH level of 11.3 these are super
alkaline substances it's like diluted
bleach bleach has an alkaline level of
only twelve point six which isn't a lot
higher on the scale when you consider
that normal water is at at level seven
so the talents people talked about
various solution draining it wasn't
really
option because it constantly refills
with rainwater they also talked about
filling it in but the cost and the
effort was just prohibitive so they came
up with a more novel solution they dyed
the lagoon black and in fact it worked
according to locals people stopped
coming to swim the lagoon instead of
looking like this beautiful little
island paradise it looked like a
cesspool it looked like a pit of doom
and despair which is exactly what they
wanted it to look like so it was kind of
a genius plan but there's one problem
they did this in 2013 as of right now
the lagoon has gone back to its original
beautiful blue color and it's only a
matter of time before the families and
the tourists start flocking take a swim
in the Blue Lagoon of Buxton subscribe
here and watch more videos here I think
that there's something else going on
here cuz I don't think the local
townspeople were so so concerned about
the well-being of the people who are
going swimming in this abandoned quarry
it may be they felt like it was a
lawsuit waiting to happen although
frankly that was on the quarry owners I
think it was more that it was kind of
embarrassing and it was becoming so
popular that it was clogging the streets
and taking a parking and there's nothing
that pisses off a small town or more
than when Outsiders come and steal all
the parking